[Music]
it is time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive discounts to start shopping
now scan the QR code on your screen or
visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Ashley
Bellman joins us now to talk about all
these good morning good morning good to
see you good to see you too I'm so happy
it's summertime all summer long
cbsdeals.com for all of the of the
summer products and right now all right
what do you got let's talk about the
calming Heat backrap this is such a
favorite so if it's applying heat
background a little bit of relaxation
here put this around
this is a back wrap that's going to
combine lumbar support it's going to
vibrate and it's going to heat and then
you just press the button it's going to
inflate to your liking okay you can wear
this when you're standing up because
it's connected to you nine different
combinations of massage of heat of the
lumbar you can wear this in the car I
used to drive two hours to and from work
if I had this it would have been a game
changer comfortable no matter where you
are in your house and think of if you're
on your feet all day long you come home
after a long day you have to watch the
kids you have to make dinner you have to
do the dishes do it well all right so
what is the uh price for the
scintillating seal is 51.99 it is 35 off
today at cbsdeals.com wow I love it I
mean it's sort of like
yeah there you go backside okay all
right next up we're heading to the beach
Memorial Day Weekend The Unofficial
start of summer this company simple
Strong's combined two Necessities I'll
give you this one okay cover up and the
towel and made it into one so these are
sarong it's a towel that you could
button on they all come with buttons so
that you don't just wrap it then it
falls off when you're running after your
toddler okay you are going to be cozy or
gonna look fabulous there are so many
different sizes okay you have options
for kids with the hoods wow really nice
um this is something that you use yeah
isn't this pretty very cool and I'm
telling you the buttons you can either
put it around your chest or around your
waist and they stay on so nicely our
friend Candy Carter is in Hawaii right
now she's rocking her simple sarong
various look how fabulous okay so how
much the candy paper so they start at
23.99 up to 38 off today all right so
cute okay all right and moving on okay
so we are bringing luxury Chic boho
style back to the beach back to the
backyard this is six and a half foot
feet in diameter has UV protection
beautiful look at The Fringe I mean this
takes me
Coast yeah get under there look at the
shade I mean this is absolutely stunning
these
umbrellas you could reuse them you could
take them everywhere they come with the
canvas bag I mean this truly this
reminds I go I grew up going to the
Jersey Shore and you're always like I'm
the one with the red umbrella and then
it's flying away you tell the people I'm
the one with the fabulous umbrella you
want to come to to hang out so how much
am I paying for this okay this is 89.99
today 45 off and you're gonna use this
every single year how much for the clam
that's free that's free for hanging out
actually Feldman thank you very much of
course we partner with all these company
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head to cbsdeals.com to start but now